it will fight on a battlefield for
America at some point in your life if
you didn't notice the words in the
background that was mr. vice president
talking to the graduates of a top class
US Military Academy and that wasn't it
how do you like this degree of certainty
it is a virtual certainty that you will
fight on a battlefield for America at
some point in your life you will lead
soldiers in combat it will happen so
what is the second most important
official in the country trying to make
clear by that the good old boots on the
ground will certainly be on the way to
quite a few different places after all
come on no one in this world would dare
to send an army against America to put
up a fight there nobody will
realistically send soldiers to attack
the superpower of all superpowers and so
men and women of West Point no matter
where you're deployed you will be the
vanguard of freedom here the ARB the
future ambassadors of freedom you look
at their faces and frankly it doesn't
seem they're in raptures over what mr.
pence is saying but let's hear where in
the world we might expect to see a boost
in freedom in the days to come some of
you will join the fight against radical
Islamic terrorists in Afghanistan in
Iraq oh these are familiar places where
the process so to say began a while ago
soon it will be 20 years any more
destinations some of you will join the
fight in Europe where an aggressive
Russia seeks to redraw international
boundaries by force probably in this
area it's a bit of an exaggeration that
the graduates will find themselves on a
battlefield taking part in NATO's big
war games there that's more like it
[Music]
well at least for now it's only been in
the form of drills for now and finally
the most curious part and some of you
may even be called upon to serve in this
hemisphere it won't be rocket science
for you to figure out where the boots on
the ground might be marching off to next
in the Western Hemisphere Venezuela
where for the White House it's a classic
all options are on the table plus we
heard from the opposition big guy there
one Guido he wouldn't mind at all it's
reflex this administration that has been
gunning for a war in Iran for a war in
Venezuela it seems to think that the
u.s. is allowed to do regime change in
other countries and take other countries
resources I think that it reflects this
idea that the United States is the only
superpower in the world and it gets to
wage war if it wants to and certainly
continue the wars that we have been in
these are wars that President Trump said
he was going to get us out of and we
continued to be in those wars supporting
other wars through proxies like Saudi
Arabia and threatening new Wars
you